today's episode is brought to you by
gray block pizza gray block pizza 18:11
Pico Boulevard in Los Angeles and they
got all caught up on all type of stuff
calzones salads silos gourmet pit pizzas
great block pizza
18:11 Pico Boulevard on the way to the
beach great block happy November happy
November to you wherever you are and I'm
so grateful you're here I'm here we out
here you know we're in this little this
little dirty daddy royal rumble we out
here taking tickling each other's
tummies you feel me we're out here just
being you know we a couple of you know
we a couple of Rutter yeah out of most
wildest little clams in the chowder
you feel me take care of brush your hair
let's get into it
[Music]
I'm just sitting on your front porch
wandering how could I be so far oh and
my mind is somewhere else but when I
found it I'll patch up where it's been
you go get your mind your mama song come
on we're here we can do it
[Music]
little town feel set that parking brake
until your story
[Music]
that is a bishop gun with shine and
that's that lead in the music right
there
welcome to this past weekend where you
where were you at right now what are you
doing what are you wearing dude are you
wearing a shirt that you like I hope
that's one thing I sometimes for me dude
if I leave the house in a shirt that I
don't like I'm not gonna be you know
real tickled about that if you see me
somewhere and I look grumpy then I
probably have on a shirt that I don't
like you know my mom's you know one time
when I was growing up my mom got a batch
of all real small shirts and I don't
know where she got them from I don't
know if you know somebody was selling
you know boxes of really small shirts or
whatever and she got a deal on that
because she used to spend time some time
with some you know miscellaneous
gentlemen here and there who was getting
deals on stuff you know she dated a
black Jewish guy when I was young so you
know she'd show up at the house with a
box of you know you know a box of you
know one size fits all neck braces and
[ __ ] like that every now and then and we
would play in the house you know plate
you know we'd play handicap at the house
and you know put on different neck
braces and you know wheel each other
around and do court house and all of
that and you know just being children
you know being young children and and
one time my mom got these shirts and and
I think probably for a year and a half
they had four different colors in the
box they had orange they had blue like
like a blue you never even seen anymore
like you know they used to have a lot
more different blues you know a long
time ago they had a lot more now they
have maybe seven different blues you
know royal blue
I think midnight blue you know you know
British blue they got that you know the
British always want to do their thang
French blue that blue that kind of you
know it says it's gonna be there for you
and then it's not there for you never
helps you out or shows up and they got
like three other blues but this was a
blue that they don't have anymore this
was kind of it was like powder blue kind
of but but a little like if somebody saw
you in it they couldn't tell maybe you
worked at the hospital or if you were
like a newborn baby it was kind of one
of those things so I guess it was like a
medical blue you know it kind of seemed
like a blue maybe you'd only put like a
newborn baby in like a baby you know a
baby blue for a boy if somebody gave
birth to a boy or it would be you know
like the scrub something like that so we
had that they had orange blue they had
paint like not pink but like purple and
green like a dark green I think they
were black but it said dark green on
them so that's one of the problems
sometimes with dark green somebody's
like oh this is these are you know
you'll buy six or seven hundred dark
green shirts but really they're just
black shirts and now you're wearing
black shirts and you're thinking you
know that your eyes don't work good and
that should always that's I don't like
it when you know companies do that to
you when they say oh you know you got
this box a dark green hitter's right
here and really they're just black
hitters and you and you're walking
around in a black shirt and telling
people this dark green and all your
friends think you're crazy and you don't
know any better because you can't you
think your eyes are bad because somebody
lied to you one of these fancy companies
lied to you but yeah my mom got some bad
shirts some small shirts and so for a
while growing up wearing those real real
small small shirts and I think you know
I know you know anxiety is something
different for everybody but sometimes I
think when I was young that's one of the
things that gave me anxiety was wearing
I mean
these were t-shirts that were be for
really almost just real athletic babies
if they had a baby that could you know
that was you know that was gonna wear a
lot of different shirts then then those
would have been for him because my mom
got about a box of bad shirts but anyhow
man um I hope that that this November is
fitting you comfortably because we're
getting into a nice time of year you
know I remember when I was young being
you know November you get outside and
you can feel you know just feeling the
cool air on your cheeks and it felt like
I just like a man like I'm not a man
I've guessed like a like a man with like
a cold tongue was just kind of licking
your cheeks a little bit and that's mr.
winner
you know that's father winter or
whatever they call him you know Chris
Krunk it not Kris Kringle but you know
that's wintertime and wintertime would
come along and it would just you know it
was fun around those times and we had a
turtleneck at our house - my mom had a
turtleneck she wore for business
meetings or something and sometimes we
would get a hold of that [ __ ] boy and
when I was young there was nothing more
fun than wearing mom's turtleneck
because you didn't have a shirt like
that you know when you're a kid that
turtleneck that's like a third sleeve
you could do whatever you want you could
put your arm out the top put your neck
out the side and then your other arm out
the other one you could do whatever you
want you you know you you got that bit
you know you got the arm coming out the
right hole you got the you know other
are coming out the left falling and you
got your other arm going out the turtle
hole see you wearing that [ __ ] you look
like a crossing guard that [ __ ] you
know that's in really in some
developmental type of clothing and I
love that man when my mom you know cuz I
would do the laundry we had different
chair chores when I was growing up to do
the laundry and that was one of mine
you know my mom made us do that when we
were real real young and we had to do it
you know we had to help out you know do
the bathroom cleaning the bathroom
you know everybody had different chores
and in and I remember sometimes with the
laundry I would do mom's laundry and I
would get to the and I get that
turtleneck plan I put that [ __ ] on and
man you could do all kinds of it was
just more of an adventurous shirt than
other regular shirts I remember a
turtleneck was really you know it was
like kind of it was going to choose your
own adventure of shirts because a
turtleneck you could pop out a different
you know you could pop up the top you
could pop out of a sleeve you know you
could do whatever you wanted and I grew
up in a neighborhood where a lot of
people look like [ __ ]
so it's like if we wore stuff that was
not really like if you should have do it
on our if you got off of our school bus
at the school and you look like [ __ ]
dude you fit right in Brooke has our bus
they brought in everybody you know how
from my street man off of Maggie Street
Brad brought in all the Wildcats you
know head lice boy we had that head lice
we showed up with the head lice people
want to start bitching then everybody
gonna start itching because we had I
mean they had head lice in our
neighborhood there was it was you could
turf wars bro you'd feel some time you
get two strands of head lice in your
hair at night and you couldn't sleep
them [ __ ] was battling and out you
know it was like se hint and it was like
um you know one of these ah
step it up like that movie step it up
we're there everybody's trying to
outdance each other and that was the
kind of thing you could feel in your
scalp if you got you know a couple
different strands a head lice at the
same time and we call them Italians head
lice because they showed up in groups
and they bothered yeah but I love this
time of year man and I hope you love it
and I'm happy to be with you guys I'm a
little tired but you know I'm always a
little tired these days then that's just
been life and that's okay I think um
I don't know if I'm tired but I'm also
kind of gratefully you know restful in
some ways I'm just you know I guess I'm
a little bit gratefully exhausted maybe
at certain in certain ways man i got
back from utah i got back from utah and
i want to apologize I didn't do the meet
and greet last night after the Saturday
shows nobody cared really I don't think
I mean some people might have cared I
was just trying to I was you know
there's been I've been you know I've
been having a lot of like just anxious
and xiety and anxious energy and it's
been hard for me to uh you know when I
get back to do the podcast sometimes
it's tough you know because I just feel
you know just a lot of stress I think
and I don't know what some of the stress
comes from I guess honestly you know
sometimes I feel you know I feel like
just more responsibility I don't know I
mean look it's different when people
start coming to see the show and people
are excited and you know it's just a new
thing you know it's a new thing in my
life and I've talked about this a little
bit before and I was thinking about it
today you know but I'm used to I'm used
to being that having that underdog kind
of thing you know I'm used to feeling
like an underdog where you know feeling
like nobody cares and so you know that's
a comfortable place for me to be at
because it always gives me like a place
to come from you know my whole life I've
always felt like I came from a place
where I felt like nobody cared and and
some of that might have been true and
some of that was that something was
rough with me where I couldn't feel I
couldn't feel when somebody did care but
now it's like people are coming out and
they're supportive of of the work and
I'm doing good work man I look I'll show
up I put on a good show I promise you
you know there's a lot of things in my
life I've done poorly but show up and
you know and share you know share these
stories and and make people laugh and
feel good and have fun I'm doing that I
am doing that and I'm I'm not gonna let
you down in that department but it's
just been different when people come out
and and it's just kind of scary like
when I've always felt like the underdog
when I've always felt like nobody cared
and to now be in a place where it feels
like people do care you know it just it
takes some I don't know it's like I mean
think if I can explain this better it
makes me just wonder well who if I'm not
the underdog you know how does this fit
on me you know I don't know how to be
kind of in that way in a little bit you
know I don't know how to be like I don't
I don't know my mom wants to say like or
my heart wants to say like grateful like
I don't know how to be I mean I know I
know I am grateful I don'ts don't know
how like I guess I feel like no matter
how much I say thank you to people that
they're not gonna believe me you know
like I don't know if something maybe
people no matter how much I say thank
you people aren't gonna believe me like
like people would never like believe
that I'm grateful or something I don't
know I'm trying to figure some of that
out you know I'm trying to talk and feel
at the same time but but I had a great
time and you know you know people came
out and it was it was nice you know some
husbands and wives a whole family came
out and this family I tell you this this
family they must have been probably
about nine feet tall or sever or seven
to nine feet and they came out in I mean
they were all laughing and the dad was
out there you know when he had something
on his cheek like a little bit of
mustard or something cuz they've been
eating you know families like to eat
together and they had fun man I'm
vámanos wiped that mustard off his cheek
and put in a moan from facehole
I almost put a writer among condiment
hold right there and ate that little dab
right off of that daddy's you know right
off that daddy's cheeky cheeky you know
I was just feeling the love I was
feeling caught up in it and we had men
it was just all the shows were sold out
and people came out and and it was it
was great it was great time somebody
gave me a nice gift it's behind me it
says uh on word on it and it's got a V
at the front and he made this himself
and this is Rawlings is this miss
Rawlings sporting woods
and this man named Lance Rawlings and
it's you can look him up Rawlings
sporting woods calm and he makes he's
really cool wooden pieces and somebody
else brought me out there WWF title belt
I don't know you know this guy was
holding it up the whole show he was
keyed up and he was fired up and he I
mean it was it was awesome and so he
gave me that strap so now this man gave
me a strap so I got I got two straps
here I got my own fighter in the kid
belt and I have this one that this man
gave me Oh what else oh I went to the
Mormon went and checked out the Mormon
Tabernacle and looked around their
beautiful campus if you if you get to go
to Salt Lake City you know one of the
special things they have there was is
Mormons and Mormons they are you know
they're gentle people
I mean morons are gentle if you ever
seen a sheep you ever seen a sheep when
it's being real real nice you ever seen
a sheep and it's being this is super
nice like you see a sheep and you're
like damn this sheep isn't being [ __ ]
nice
that's Mormons they're friendly man you
can marry anybody you know we're walking
through the scenery there through the
campus down there and on Temple Avenue
and in salt downtown Salt Lake City and
they they got weddings going on
everywhere they had 11 weddings going on
do you go pick somebody up and pick a
rose off a thing and tickle a preacher
for two seconds and next thing you know
your hitch to ever you're holding on to
yeah everywhere you turned around it was
there was just you were in a wedding you
were walking in a procession or into a
you know you were catching a bouquet did
I probably you know I probably caught
six bouquets for about 48 yards it was
it was stunning just a lot of love
there's a lot of love in that group you
know definitely people start looking a
little bit similar because you don't do
a lot of Janette you know if you're not
incorporating too much extra genetics
every now and then then people started
looking a little bit similar but damn it
was a beautiful community beautiful
community and and so it was nice man it
was nice to just see you know see that
community walk around just friendly
people they had a man out there he was
you know selling different spices and
stuff he had his own little spice cart
this little older guy reminded me when I
was growing up actually they had this
dude my dad knew named cinnamon Wilson
and this guy and thought about this guy
forever when I was a child
cinnamon Wilson was his dude he he would
let us like car like I guess a lick a
little bit of cinnamon out of his hand
because we didn't always have cinnamon
now you know I'm living in a you know a
different world these days I got
cinnamon at the house but when I was
young we had you know we didn't have as
much cinnamon as we wanted and cinnamon
now kids are screwing around they doing
cinnamon challenges and they're hiding
you know hiding cinnamon between their
you know their buttocks and stuff like
that and and staring into the Sun and
just doing wild you know unnecessary
tricks but when I was young you didn't
get cinnamon all the time you had it you
didn't have as many flavors you had
orange grape you know peppermint you
could get that anywhere but cinnamon
that was a special flavor and my dad's
buddy cinnamon Wilson brah or mr. Wilson
but we called him cinnamon Wilson he put
a little bit of cinnamon in his hand I
guess he would maybe wet his hand or
something either you know lick it or cry
into it a little bit and then he would
put some cinnamon in
and he'd hold the cinnamon down by us
while he was talking to my dad he let us
lick it out of his hand and he was
gentle you know he had the big soft
senior-citizen hands you know cuz my dad
at that time my dad was probably 75
years old so all of my dad's friends
were 75 and man if you were licking
cinnamon off of his hand it fell I mean
it almost was like a cake sometimes you
almost wanted to just bite right into
his damn hand meat like it was a coffee
cake or something and he'd be real chill
about it and he wasn't a pervert or
anything like that he wasn't you know he
wasn't you know you didn't see his pants
you know expound and in the front or any
you know he wasn't touching your hair
trying to steal a little you know cut
part of your hair off and keep it at his
house or anything wicked he was just he
liked givin things to people I guess and
he was a bird trainer too and he also
had birds all the time so he was used to
feeding you something out he out of his
hand so he you know he sometimes he [ __ ]
up he'd reach in his pocket and next
thing you know you got you know you got
a mouthful of all you got a mouthful of
birdseed you know like [ __ ] I thought I
was getting you know some of that tasty
sweet powder that sent him on baby cuz
cinnamon was when I was young cinnamon
was brand-new now cinnamon is old hat
now they got all kind of new stuff
kratom and these kids are on our you
know what else
ginko biloba all of that you know what
else are kids doing nowadays tangerine
they didn't have that [ __ ] when I was
young when I was young we had more you
know cinnamon was a new something
brand-new so if you saw mr. Wilson he
[ __ ] hit you with that low palm you
know hand down with a little and he'd go
over there and just get you a couple of
[ __ ] tongue whips at that sin Imam
morning and then the other kids would
see you getting my brothers and sisters
would see me get it and they want to get
a little hit of it so it was pretty fun
it was like a fun game but he was a bird
trainer and he would train
birds you know and he well I guess he
didn't train him really but he would
like feed him and just look at him for a
long time you know but some people call
him training and and he ate a lot of
bird eggs too that's one thing about the
man when I look back on him because he
passed now he's with Christ or whomever
he you know whomever he favors but he
did he'd have all kind of eat he I'll
say this he was doing stuff he shouldn't
been doing with the bird eggs because
here we have all hell of a damn
nightingale omelette like what the hell
is that I don't think I think you know
not supposed to have that and you go
over there and he'd have a damn duck
omelette like what the [ __ ] because I
grew up where I'm from you just have
chicken omelets in Vietnam and some
places like that they got you know they
have the balut duck eggs they got all
those fear factor snacks and stuff like
that that fear factor breakfast buffet
people out there drinkin buggin you know
quarts and quarts of rawness or simin
but I don't do we went drinking big
animal semen in our area when I was
growing up we had regular [ __ ] but he
would have that's one thing in hindsight
he shouldn't have been doing probably
some of those birds is harvesting their
eggs and making you know unique or
extracurricular style armless because
you'd see that dude he'd be having a
[ __ ] you know tomato with Sparrow
omelet you're like what the [ __ ] is that
he's over there really harvesting but
man we had a good time in Utah thank you
to the people that came out I do I you
know I don't know if I apologize for not
doing the the meet and greet on Saturday
I was just honest I was just exhausted
and I just needed it to kind of do some
things to take care of myself so I
wasn't trying to be selfish but you know
I don't know man I'm just still kind of
learning what it's like to have people
come out into you know a lot of this
kind of stuff is I don't know I it's
like being in like a new relationship or
something I don't know I can't explain
it and maybe I'm overthinking it in some
ways but
you know but a lot of good people come
out to these shows I can't tell I can't
explain that to you enough I've been
doing this comedy 450 for 15 years and
over the time I've had some [ __ ]
Jackrabbits and damn do one time I
remember being in Toledo and they had
like an arsonist recovery group and I'm
all about recovery you know that 12
steps I'm on 144 steps man I need all I
need to just constantly be on the
staircase but these boys he's with some
arsonists you know them [ __ ] you know
just a bunch of damn candles or rose I
mean they'll [ __ ] light a candle and
just try you know burn down a damn dog
house or something and I respect him and
stuff but you know that's the kind of
people that were out there getting free
tickets people that used to burn in down
hospital you know arsonists people it
does arson you know the kind of guy who
likes a cigarette and that ain't enough
then next thing you know he's like aw
[ __ ] he'll hold that lighter against the
side of a damn federal building for an
hour and a half so but to have people
that are really coming out in that you
know in that care and it's just exciting
and it's an excitement that in some ways
I'm just getting used to and and then
it's a lot you know you get it's a lot
and it's new and you know I hadn't been
taking good care of myself I've been
trying to do more working out and
staying athletic and you know getting my
blood going just to keep my brain in a
more comfortable place because I guess I
just feel like some more responsibility
and stuff these days but I'm grateful to
the people that came out if I didn't get
to meet you then we'll do it next time
and II and thank you guys very much in
Utah
what else I have DC and Lexington coming
up and then we got a but we do there's a
bunch of new dates for the spring and
I'm so excited I think late spring it's
looking like I'm going to you know jump
across the pond maybe in both directions
for Australia and the UK
so that should be good stuff
as always you can hit the hotline to be
a part of the show in that number is
nine eight five six six four nine five
zero three and I'm happy to be home man
you know I had a nice time knowing in
Salt Lake City it's a beautiful city and
you need skin moisturizer though in Salt
Lake City if you're going to Salt Lake
City and you don't have any moisturizer
you might not make it
did I woke up in the morning I'm
scratching an itch and I'm bleeding on
it you know my elbows and stuff
everything is dry my mind feel you know
my mouth tastes like I may be you know
like old cinnamon Wilson hit me with
about nine handfuls while I was sleeping
I'm dried out I thought a damn scorpion
was gonna just crawl out of one side of
my mouth because I was just you know
it's dry so I say if you go up there
take extra water you know the airport
should let you bring water to Utah
because you need take extra water
moisturizer [ __ ] I don't care if you buy
a couple damn bags of plasma off the you
know off the black web or whatever but
show up because that [ __ ] you'd be dried
out do you you show up it'll be you sure
you have a 9th birthday party in in Salt
Lake City and by the time it's over you
look about 35 David se you get the
moisture do moisture as God's um butter
cream and he put it in us cuz he wants
us to stay frothy and in there and
they're not doing that very well in Utah
but a beautiful place I want to go visit
my buddy Josh Kelly and he is uh he's a
musician and he I used to work as a tour
manager for him one of my first Jobs was
tour managing for mr. Joshua Kelly and
he's had some good hits over the years
and he comes from a very talented family
and he has a farm up there and they got
pigs and little you know Wow goats and
they got foster children I'm not
counting those his animals they're
beautiful he's got two beautiful little
foster girls
and it just really lifted my heart up in
a lot of ways you know it's really
special when you see somebody doing
foster care and doing it well and just
you know just opening their arms and
their their lives and their hearts and
their wallets you know to help you know
to help some young children and one of
his foster children is from Louisiana
and hopefully my talking outside a shop
or outside of school here but you know
she its kind of spat you know for me
just being from Louisiana it was just
it's just kind of a special thing so we
went over there and petted the animals
by his house they got donkeys and they
got some fainting you know whatever
those are a little faint and javelinas
or something they had Christmas bells on
and do it it's beautiful I know that ant
you know I don't you know I've seen some
animals I've seen an animal get hit by
lightning I've seen a Doberman jump out
the back of a dam you know a Nissan
truck doing about 80 on the interstate
and he did it by himself that Doberman
he didn't want to be alive I guess but
but I've never seen uh you know they
have one of these you know these have a
lean as they got these jingle bells on
them for the holidays and then they're
like fainter so if they get spooked or
something they faint they hit this they
hit the ground and it's almost like
musical chairs you know you are excited
to hear them the music from the jingle
bells and then an egg pane out and hit
the ground so pretty cool to see them
have he's dropping like that but we had
some great calls that came in I'm gonna
get to a couple of them and thank you
guys so much for coming out in Utah and
happy early holidays this is a good time
you know this is a good time new you
know stretch your arms out wide and then
wrap them around somebody else this that
hug and season could people are cold and
a hug that's like a that's a [ __ ]
that's a little scarf you know when you
show up with somebody when you hug them
you put them in that soft scarf you know
you do that in the summertime you're
kind of a pervert you a creep you
you a toucher you know but you do that
in the wintertime boy you just [ __ ]
giving them that full front body
cinnamon Wilson you feel me just with
just people willing to get that mad if
they're cold and you hug them go hug
somebody that's cold watch them smile
let's get to a couple calls that came in
man thank you guys so much as always the
hotline is nine eight five six six four
nine five zero three we had a great time
with our single mom came out
I want to thank Justin and Roman and I'm
forgetting his name right now Justin and
Roman and one other lovely gentleman who
came out and filmed and recorded our
single mom voluntarily
you know voluntarily man and just really
man just so kind and it was a hurt you
know and I was like you know I got there
like ten minutes late typical date you
know typical man date you know I'm
showing up a few minutes late or me
typical me so I get there and we took
the lady out to the California's Pizza
Kitchen and they got other stuff they
say pizza but they got salads you know
and what else we went to an escape room
and played a game she came out and
brought her sister out a mother of three
and breezy that's her name this girl
straight breezy you know and that [ __ ]
was you know category four wins baby she
you know she was definitely breezing
past everybody you know she was you know
if she tipped you know she'd tickle your
nickel if you you know you feel her go
by she's really quite a current of a
woman and a beautiful young mother of
three and we went out and had a nice
time and those guys volunteered their
time and they went and planned ahead and
you know it's a great time of year to do
that to fill other people's hearts with
your time and your ability and they just
reminded me of that they reminded me of
it's funny even if I'm somewhere helping
out I'm I'm somewhere we're taking the
mom out
I don't always feel like I'm doing
something for some reason but those guys
man they showed up and you know
capturing the audio and video and it was
man it was fun it was really really fun
I'll put a picture of him of us up on
the instagrams so you can see it but
let's get to a couple calls that came in
as always the hotline nine eight five
six six four nine five zero three we got
some really really great ones people
calling in about you know helping out
with nut vember people staying on the
grind and staying off their little meet
you know meet shooter and trying not to
do touch touch at the house you know try
not to [ __ ] feed cinnamon to their
Wilson you feel me as always I want to
let you know that today's episode is
brought to you by hello fresh and look
there's a lot of things I wouldn't eat
well
is that true actually I just [ __ ]
admitted that I've eaten sentiment out
of a man's hand that I you know that my
dad barely knew but there's a company
called hellofresh and this past weekend
is supported in part by hellofresh and
it's a great service if you want to
spend time with your children or your
spouse in the kitchen leave your phones
out in the living room or lock them out
in the car something or in the van if
y'all got a van or something or hide
them in the garage and you can be or and
you spend time you and your spouse you
cutting the radishes you know your uh
you know maybe you hug you know your how
you're reaching around your spouse cuz
you wanna you know you know feel the
noodle soup or whatever you you're
spending time together that's what
hellofresh does and that's great food
they deliver the ingredients right to
your house and it's quick you can make
it fast but you're still spending time
together I think it's a great fit for
today's lifestyles and it delivers your
favorite recipes and pre-measured
ingredients so if you got the kid there
and he ain't doing well in school at
least he could you know this is like you
know anybody that's got a C average can
make this stuff they have three plans to
choose from classic veggie and family
each box
they sing you to Bachman it's nice nice
the gun [ __ ] you guys you know you could
use the box for other stuff if you want
you know get a little animal and put it
under there they got holes in the box
that animal can breed you could do that
later for dessert and just pet the
animal the non edible dessert just
before ending a creature but each box is
made up of fresh responsibly obtained
ingredients from carefully selected
farms and high rated trusted sources
recipes take around 30 minutes they get
delicious filling meals delivered right
to your door it's healthy it's good and
I promise you it is fun and I'm not
joking
this is a real joy especially this time
of year
slow it down do something with your
loved ones go into the year with a built
up bank of of just worth and value and
esteem and I know I'm putting a lot on
hellofresh but you know I like it for
$20 off your first three boxes which is
a total of $60 off visit hellofresh comm
slash th EO six zero and enter promo
code th EO six zero that's hellofresh
comm slash Theo number six number zero
code Theo number six number zero for a
total of $60 off okay let's get into a
couple calls here we got this one right
here oh man what's up Theo this is Chris
calling from Long Island New York this
is my Chris Long Island strong Island
baby and I don't know why they call it
Long Island I mean it's prom you know
well I'm an idiot probably long and
feels kind of lonesome like I do
sometimes on work
I call it a podcast I don't think it
would be interesting I just wanted to
let you know I just listened to the nut
remember podcast last week and at the
end yep and I'm going on right now let
me see I got about six days that I'd
juicy juicy in me right now you know if
you hear something kind of if when I'm
talking you hear a little bit of gurgle
in the back of my throat that's my Chi
building
cuz I'm nut it up you know I got that I
got that Simon stack starting to build
in the back of me you know that's what
I'm saying that ye and we can do that
you know you can hold on your new hold
the line viet nut this is our viet not
onward you said this was a most selfish
podcast man and the whole time i listen
to this podcast i was thinking this is
his best ever most helpful podcast just
useful funny just your heart came across
in that one and i could i just couldn't
let it go that at the end you thought it
was so selfish but I know it wasn't I
just know it wasn't so I'm just calling
letting you know I appreciate you I'm
getting emotional I appreciate you a lot
just keep doing everything you're doing
the same way thanks man
all more sorry alright you're not gonna
call back with my phone numbers and just
you're doing great in it you're the best
man okay yeah thanks for calling me and
appreciate the message I uh yeah I don't
know why man I I think I've just been
feeling really strange recently I just
been feeling like I don't know I've just
been feeling like not that good to be
honest with you you not has been feeling
like I don't know like no matter what I
do like it's not enough you know and I
don't know why I feel that way sometimes
and I'm kind of time on esteem in I'm
kind of tired of it you know tired of
feeling that way
and I don't know if it's cause like we
live in like a time now where it like
makes you feel like you have to always
be doing stuff or you know maybe I'm
getting older and I'm starting to just
think about like you know just what the
vow like you know what's important now
but I appreciate you saying that that's
nice of you mean you know what let me
get this hitter right here this is the
free we live in 2018 I can call back let
me see what
oh hey Chris yeah hey what up man this
is Theo man I'm doing good man I was
just listening to your message man I
thought it was real real nice of you did
I just wanted to call and say thanks
that was such a great podcast when you
said it was so good I don't know I never
feel like : well I appreciate you man
for one it's nice to hear in New York
accent dude it makes me feel like I'm
doing something with my life you know it
makes me feel like I'm caught up into
something you know like I'm caught up
into the underworld of like you know
some type of mafia style in my brain you
know I got a bunch of friends I turned
on yeah and we all we all really
appreciate it but I am I really you know
I go through some similar struggles and
I'm trying to get sober myself and and
as far as the Minnesota thing to say but
do it like I relate to all of it and I
get from it and I just appreciate it so
much I really appreciate you so much
brother
well thanks dude yep yeah yeah I guess I
don't know why I just feel like that
sometimes man I guess I just feel yeah I
don't know it's like I'll do a episode
or something and then I just feel like I
don't know like I just didn't I don't
know I don't know I just been feeling I
think really strange like not being able
to like feel like of you sir of value
you know really really yeah man I guess
I guess I could understand it but it's
hard for me to believe it because I feel
like you must be getting so much love
that right now you must be no deal ya
know I get a lot of yeah I get a lot of
um yeah get a lot of people that you
know send nice messages send nice DMS
people come out to the show and say nice
stuff I don't know what it is man well I
was listening your your voicemail and it
just kind of hit me I was like now
then I don't know why I don't have like
a like a healthy view of like just
whatever is going on in my own world you
know yeah yeah but man that makes a lot
of sense to me because I've been a
teacher I'm in a public school teacher
for 11 years and I get the most
beautiful letters written to me by my
students about how much I've affected
them and help them and touch them and
they learn from me but yet in my own
personal life I'm still all for covering
my head and I do the things I wanna do
and like I got two daughters and I'm
gonna know I'm a good dad but yet still
I can't get out of my own way you want
to come into my own health and just
being okay with me fully yeah I guess
it's just I guess is not just everything
you get back I guess it's hard to
explain that yeah we got a like at the
practice we got to keep working on it
maybe you know yeah I don't know I mean
even while you're saying that it's got
me kind of thinking about it ya know
that's so wild that we can't yeah it's
like we won't give ourselves I guess
it's like I'm scared to feel like good
about myself because it's like I don't
know if I just don't know like I'm what
if I start feeling good about myself am
I gonna feel like too good about myself
am I gonna be become like a bad person I
don't know I don't know it's like you're
full of doubt like just full of doubt
like you that's not sure I mean but it
sounds like you just like doubtful yeah
like I don't deserve to feel like I
don't know if I don't deserve to feel
good but like if somebody I don't know I
don't know man this is interesting
that's why when I heard this I was like
Olga and you left your number I was like
I'm gonna freakin call as dude back no
I'm keeping you on the line too long you
just wanted to call to say you
appreciate it though I appreciate you
calling me yeah you bet man thanks so
much dude and this is my number you have
it if you need something hit me up if I
can give you some suggestions or
something about the cast you know uh but
yeah I don't know man I don't know what
that is I think I you know maybe some
money to just think about more talking
to like a therapist or friends about
just yeah why just like
is it you really feel like you're not
doing the right thing or you what is it
I just feel like just yeah just
disconnected or I just feel I don't know
I feel like I'll from what everyone says
la is a hard place to really connect
with people on that level I guess I
don't know if that part of it or yeah no
it definitely is it's not like yeah you
don't have a lot of like connective
conversations and stuff out here I don't
know you know I don't know what it is
that maybe I just need to go to more
meetings and just kind of like listen to
others you know or something I don't
know what it is but yeah man I
appreciate the Coleman is really nice of
you dude who's like the nicest thing I
got so thank you oh thank you keep doing
you I wish you the best of luck and all
and all my love and - thank you so much
thank you yeah you've ever uh there have
a good day man happy early holidays yo
good night cheers brother
well that was nice of him man no just
nice of him to say that you know I'm
gonna listen back to his call one more
time here so I can get another vibe for
it Chris caller from Long Island New
York this is not a call to the podcast
I don't think it would be interesting I
just wanted to let you know I just
listened to the nut remember podcast
last week and at the end you said this
was the most selfish podcast man and the
whole time I listen to this podcast I
was thinking this is his best ever most
helpful podcast just useful funny just
your heart came across in that one yeah
I don't know why I just been feeling so
cell I don't know why I've been feeling
selfish I don't know what that is inside
of me that mate I just feel selfish man
you know and honestly that I just feel
kind of like this is gonna seem crazy
man I just feel like ashamed of myself
for some reason
you know I don't know why I think maybe
he just I don't know I think part of me
feels like you know I don't have all the
tools like you know to know if I'm like
not gonna fail myself you know um yeah I
don't know why man I don't know why I
just feel I just feel like I'm not and
I'm not look I'm not looking for like
people to say look you're doing a good
job and stuff like that I'm trying to
just feel my feelings you know you know
I'm not afraid of my feelings impacted I
want I wish I had more feelings because
then I know what's going on with me you
know what I don't have any feelings
that's I think that's someone what's
been going on or is having been having a
lot of feelings and so then I get scared
you know because like you know ever
since I got into like a a and started
doing sobriety and that I started having
a lot more feelings you know and it saw
him for the first time my whole life so
I started like you know for like the
first time in my life I felt like I like
a living person you know because before
that all my feelings were just like in
my head like all my feelings were just
like strong thoughts and understanding
of moments and like you know I had seen
moments on television and so I knew how
to act and all these moments and stuff
but I and I was present and I cared but
I just didn't I couldn't feel that good
and then I got an a a and I could just
feel better or I could feel at all and I
think maybe others been having going to
enough meetings or like I don't know I
think just a lot going on you know you
know and a lots been going on in my life
it's been just a different experience
it's been a different experience you
know going from like being the chip on
your shoulder feeling like the underdog
and then I guess you know I'll just
worry that like if I start to be like
you know not the underdog or start to be
successful then I'm just gonna like
alienate like
person like I'm gonna alienate like the
kid who I always felt that like nobody
cared about you know if that makes any
sense
like suddenly like if I start to like
live in this place in my life where more
people care then I'm like letting go of
like the kid that I've always are the
person I've always been who I felt you
know growing up and stuff was just
somebody that nobody cared about I think
something like that there's something to
do with that I don't know but you know I
don't know I'm not trying to make
everybody you know I'm not trying to
like have a Debbie Downer type of day or
anything like that man I'm not I'm not
sad you know I'm just you know I'm just
trying to monitor you know what's going
on with me and how I feel and it's just
been a little bit different and I've
always only known kind of one way to be
you know and it's hard to yeah it's
weird it's like I don't want to hear
people tell me that I'm good at
something you know I don't want to hear
that like I don't want to hear it like
at a deep level like I can hear it up
here in my ears yeah I can hear it I can
say thank you I'm glad you have fun you
know but I think at a deep level I don't
want to hear people you know I'm not mad
at people that say nice things that's
not what I'm saying that's just like at
a deeper level if I hear that I don't
know I don't know a deeper level
somebody if I hear somebody tell me that
you know I just think I know somewhere
inside of me I always wanted to hear
that you know even though I didn't even
know that I needed to hear it you know
when I was young I just wanted to tell
somebody just you know somebody who
loved me to tell me that they you know
that I was doing a good job you know and
then I was okay and then I was just a
good you know I was just a good kid you
know that I was okay even if someone
wasn't doing good you know that I was
okay and I think now as an adult you
know having people be excited and having
people say you're good at this or you
know it's just you know it's like a new
skin you know and I'm grateful but it's
just a look you know it's so it's like
an emotional kind of learning curve and
stuff and I'm not trying to sound like
egomaniacal or anything man I look you
know we may never said I may never say
we may never sell another ticket to a
comedy show and I'm back just [ __ ]
you know telling riddles to [ __ ]
arsonists you know one dude was throwing
lit matches on the stage what bah what
are you doing dude but but yeah anyway
so that's just I don't know that but
anyway Chris that's why I feel sometimes
I guess I I don't know I'll get a good
more meetings I think and just get more
dialed in but anyway I didn't mean to
get in a weird space I'm so grateful for
the you know for this opportunity to
come home and have this here to talk and
listen you know and I thought it was
nice of Chris to call and leave that
message you know I think we live in a
different age these days where it's okay
you know do young men need a lot of help
you know young men need a lot of help
you know you know there's this there's
this attack
there's this I do feel sometimes like
it's like it's not an attack on young
men but there's there very much I feel
like being neglected you know in society
and I feel like a lot of the choices
that we've been led to my stronger
powers
in the world and stuff like that have
led us away from you know having having
some you know helping our men to learn
and to grow emotionally and and I'm and
I'm part of the problem I'm a victim of
all of that I think not like a victim
like woe is me like I need to put a damn
tourniquet or something or you know bum
one of those [ __ ] neck braces as
one-size-fits-all even though I have
more Giudice to wear a children's medium
even up to last year but my neck has
always been real short and I've always
had like kind of that shorter neck and
I've wanted more of a mediums net and I
would wear a children's medium neck
brace to kind of get that extra [ __ ]
quarter inch you know at night I would
lay there and keep it on for about eight
minutes because you're not supposed to
keep one for longer than eight minutes
if you're not you know that's not doctor
recommended anyway
let's say let's take another call man
onward hey dude I just want to call and
apologize bro I like your show last
night I went by myself got a little
nervous and have some drinks too and I
started sort of whooping hollering a
little too much up front big let's go
bad I feel real bad honestly so I just
want to call it apologize man I hope you
don't hold it against me
I [ __ ] love the [ __ ] out of you man
great show and yeah man keep doing what
you're doing I appreciate the apology
man yeah I forgive you bro you know I
appreciate it
I you know I don't handle those things
sometimes super great sometimes I do
okay but my thing is you know and I
understand yet you know you're excited
and you you know people have too many
drinks and then you don't even know then
you just work in freelance for vodka you
know suddenly you're employed by vodka
and you know you clocked in for work but
it's just tough sometimes if the show
like you know cuz I want everybody to
enjoy it and you know you know some
comedians they work real hard on the art
and putting it out there and we just
want it to be a fun experience so I
don't mind people being a part of the
show I just don't want them to try and
make this show about them cuz yeah I
mean it cuz of the show because I don't
feel like this shows about me like
I feel like it's the show you know I'm
not up there the whole time like a look
at me I'm up there thinking let's make
it fun let's you know this is how we're
gonna do it this is what we'll you know
let's let's make it a joyous time and so
that's what happens sometime when
somebody gets you know when you clock in
and you work him for you know whatever
you drinking over there if you drinking
sometime a lady I seen this lady the
other night she had a little one of
those long straws that you know where
one could have been a damn hospital bag
she might have been a registered
assistant or something or you know when
it implies my jockeys or one of those
ladies that comes in at night and he's
stealing players might have senior
citizens and that shit's happening all
over over there in some of these
different communities the Hasidic
community I think they call it somebody
doing it and where else I think um over
in Haiti and they got people popping in
it's you know they siphoning plasma out
of somebody's step-uncle or whatever but
yeah but this lady had one of those
things going into her purse she's
[ __ ] sipping on some secret sauce
right there out of a damn you know
Pierre cardigan or whatever the damn you
know purse brand is these ladies are
listen you know what are the you know I
don't know what it's called Bed Bath and
briefcase whatever ladies are carrying
things around in she's sipping out of
that hitter right there
so yeah just you know I want you to I
want everybody to have fun and I don't
[ __ ] it's your life here's what I say
I appreciate your apology man it's nice
of you to call let's take another call
here we go yo video this is a game from
Las Vegas what's up from Los Vegas boy
and that's the devil's
butthole beautiful people out there
though dude beautiful people out there
in the desert people
Las Vegas everything's is just the strip
but they got a lot of real serious good
people out there you know a lot of
Latinos a lot of white people with
sunburn
you know they got a lot of people out
there raising dogs a lot of animal
rescue the one dude died that [ __ ]
titty maverick whatever his name is was
you know captain luau
you know luau Pacino or whatever that
guy was the desert you know posse
captain anyway
onward I'm calling in about Sydney from
Monday's podcast she said she was having
issues with her boyfriend watching porn
behind her back
Oh Yin let's well - I'm real quick we're
gonna go back to the nut vember podcast
episode last week for a couple seconds
you can listen to her call and she was
having issues sexually issues and
sensual activity issues with her and her
man because of Homme
voilá graffia this is Sydney in Oklahoma
I did find out not too long ago that my
boyfriend had been watching porn behind
my back he does know that I am against
it for my own personal reasons
okay so your boyfriend was watching the
pornography behind your back and that's
really a fun place to watch it I'll be
honest you know that's makes you but
that make it feel more secretive so you
heard that and let's pop back into your
call now thank you for calling homeward
and just wanting to give a little tip
can probably uh you know dabble in the
filmmaking a little bit send them some
naughty photos videos something to uh to
get his mind off the pornography to
replace the pornography and honestly
does a man have to be any new videos
most guys do just fine with like now you
send a video uh cutting some watermelon
in a bra maybe some strawberries you
know that's more than enough for those
guys yeah oh yeah and that's a nice idea
right there you know and I think if a
woman is to do this or a man is to do
this if you dating a man and you're a
man and you prefer to company a men you
know you like that longer process you
feel me then what I'm saying is if you
want to send some nudity of yourself
that's kind of yes if especially if your
spouse or your partner whatever
has a problem if there's if they're
suffering and that's what she was saying
her call she's saying that she believes
that the pornography has affected their
you know sensual activities you know
playing you know really close game a
freeze tag you know what I'm saying
you're red you're red you feel me sexual
doing full sexual and so yeah maybe
that's one thing you could do do some
real naughty things and and here's
another tip if you're gonna send some
nudity's of yourself don't sing your
face in them if you're a man or why
don't care what you sending ladies don't
send your face it's not that big just to
protect yourself don't don't be like you
know it's you don't to do that you know
some ladies that would you know they'll
be naked they'll sing you that nudie and
they don't have like a makeup on or have
a hat on you don't need that just the
body because the you know man especially
there's thinking at that point sexual or
maybe I'm just thinking that and maybe
that's my problem
you know and that's one of the side
effects of pornography that's really
negative is and I'll say this for myself
and I know this for a fact
you start to think of sex in like frames
you know you start to think of sex in
the same way that it's shot in the
videos like okay I've see someone I meet
them okay now we're in bed now we're in
this lewd position and I'm envisioning
this you know this little crotch area or
something and I'm in you know I'm seeing
the titties out there some are seeing
them balls if you do in the wild you
know if you out there you know boar
hunting or whatever chasing men but but
they you know and then next thing you
know I see this and then this it's just
you think of sex in frames in specific
moments more than you think of it as one
big buffet you think of it as okay
here's a side item there's a side item
there's a side item there's a side item
first aside I don't we walk in them
you know in your place the second side
item
we lay down weed you know look at each
other's booties or whatever the third
side item we doing you know oral
copulation or something you know playing
that you know doing the lippy sticky or
whatever and then the third the last one
doing full sexual and that and then you
got and then that's it and then
everybody busts out at the end and then
next thing you know it's you know you
know you chilling man that's it you know
that's it
aftermath rendezvous that's it M&M but
what you don't realize is the buffet of
sex is a bigger thing it's more you over
here and you're looking at this you
touching you're holding hands you know
you looking and they got dirty
silverware you ask them for clean
silverware you see in the different
types of letters you see and they got
black olive they got red olives you know
they got some bruised strawberries over
here they got this they got the legs
feet butt cheeks hair you see in
everything it's a fuller picture and
pornography kills that full picture and
it just cuts it up in the scenes and so
that's my problem that I have sometimes
I've noticed for myself anyway
it's a view because then you start to
view that experience with a woman just
in in in still images and moments and
sex and still images and moments and
okay I need to see this I need to see
this I need to see this and then
everybody needs to do full bust you'll
and that's life but that's not it
that is a program that runs through us
because pornography is dirty because
that's dark arts there's dark arts
central pornography I mean the devil
must remind as well just be damned you
know might as well just have put his
brain right into a damn flat you know
into a computer and uploaded it right
into your life but here's what I'll say
this is this that [ __ ] well we're not
talking about Oh ladies we're gonna send
nude yeah you
can do now you could send some
pornography to your man and I think I
know I love this idea the end idea let's
play it again to get his mind off the
pornography to replace the pornography
and honestly it doesn't have to be any
news videos most guys do just fine with
like you sent a video of cutting some
watermelon in a bra maybe some
strawberries you know that's more than
enough for those guys now yeah I agree
you can do something romantic you could
be you know shooting an arrow or
something off the roof or something
maybe you're in a skirt or you could do
you know I do like this idea of
reframing what pornography is maybe you
wearing a little you know um a security
guard outfit or something with you know
it's a slice or something that got like
a assless security guard outfitting you
running down you know chasing a fake
criminal or doing I don't like the knife
and the vegetables I can't get hard to
run a knife so if I see a knife I'm not
getting erect but that's me but some
guys you know maybe if your husband is
you know he's from New Jersey Rees part
of Native American or whatever he can
handle it I can't handle that you know
broken glass and knifes no deke deke for
daddy but a lot of men can handle that
but I love this idea of reframe so
because then here's what's gonna happen
if a lady tells you that okay let's uh
I'm gonna send you some pornography now
you know that a she's trying to work
with you on this problem that you have
if you have a problem this only for men
that have problem I'm not saying every
men have problem but but a good way to
reframe it yeah is if your lady wants to
send you something maybe she's just
doing math you know maybe she's doing
math and she have uh um you know a wife
beater on with you know when they got
the breasts open areas they got rips
over their breasts or they got you know
maybe she's eating soup and she got some
you know when they she gets you got a
little buddy over there painting her
tail toenails or something
she got a gay friend at the house
painting her toenails and she's having
some soup
you know or if you like a man if you
prefer you know a sex man then what you
can have then is maybe your man you know
he's butt-naked and he's chasing uh um
you know he's taking you know he's got a
little dachshund or a Bichon or
something
and he's taking that [ __ ] for a walk or
something you know he's taking that
beautiful little lovely creature for a
snack or something he's in fully nude or
he's wearing like a um a cooking apron
in one of those neck braces or something
there's definitely new ways to say hey
this is what pornography is now let's
make it new and exciting I like that
idea thank you for that call let's take
another call that was in response to um
to sending from last week onward hi this
is Jalen from Virginia I'm actually
calling in to respond to Sydney from
Oklahoma who was talking about her
boyfriend and how she doesn't like him
watching porn yup we got that call and
thank you for your call um onward I
think a good compromise if the reason
for you not liking him watching porn
um is because you don't like the idea of
him lusting after other women maybe um
instead of making him stop watching porn
maybe you guys can make porn together
maybe send him a couple of nude pictures
or shoot a video or record a video as
you can making love so and he does
masterly it's um he's doing it to you
and he's celebrating your body and in
celebrating the love that you to mate
that's a nice thought man that's
beautiful that's like the hallmark
pornography channel this guy just sent
us in and that makes me feel good yeah
do something and make a pornography
together make it a thing you do together
somehow you know one thing that would be
neat about that if you did that you know
in a in a unique way you're gonna take a
lot of the power out of that pornography
for him because one of the things about
pornography where
hurts men is it become something we do
by ourself it becomes this kind of like
hidden act people in watching
pornography out there you know during a
soccer game you know you're not watching
pornography at a are at a Fiesta you
know at a Carl's jr. actually you might
at a Carl's jr. on if you're Bernal
Carl's jr. at night but some of the
lights don't work inside and people are
lonely eating big sandwiches and I've
always said that that Carl's jr. is
really a mecca for lonely men and big
sandwiches but oh so if you want to do
pornography together that yet you're
gonna take a lot of that power if you do
something with your man together and
make it together ladies instead of
ostracizing your man you're gonna make
it really really healthy for him I think
you're gonna have a chance to make it a
new experience for him and the truth is
man what we all need in a lot of ways is
a new experience with something because
man there's when you're a man you've
been masturbating for you know 13 years
nine years it's a long that's a lot of
sexual energy that you've just been
using by yourself and you're you know
you're at home the when you know you got
the windows closed usually unless you
Jamaican or something I mean a Jamaican
person they bust out with the damn
windows open they'll fire that right out
in the air a damn seagull or combine
just you know that's lunch and that's
the Lunch Bunch but most people they
closed the blinds it's a lonely thing
you do it's a lonely thing you do it's
something you do by yourself just alone
so I'm just lonesome activity it's not
an exercise I mean it's funny you're
busting and looking but outside of that
the side effects of it are and the
practice of it as you do it by yourself
you close its secret if you do by
yourself so then it feels like this you
know but for a woman I then say hey well
let's see what if we do this together I
ask your man why do you like this make
him really think about it let him know
you're not going to judge him if he
answers in an uncomfortable or strange
way
and then I think you know there could be
some progress in that area and I feel
bad that women have to deal with this
you know and that men probably are
starting to have to deal with the - we
don't even realize and I mean some
people might think do you're crazy
talking about pornography this much man
I'm telling you I'm telling you we don't
know the long-term side effects of this
is having on humanity but I'll guarantee
you they are not decent decent let's
hear another call homeward
what's up Co my name is Grady I'm
calling in regards to this woman Cindy
that called in on the last podcast and
without some questions about her
boyfriend and how she can help him yep
now sending all right onward as he's
struggling was always looking at
pornography he that pika-pika guy and
I'm that piki guy you know I'm five days
full right now Baba beat sheep have you
any wool yes sir yes sir
five days full homeward um I sent a book
recommendation I really wanted to be
able to offer it's this book I'm reading
that's called unwanted by Jay stringer
and it's a book about sexual brokenness
he's a Christian but I bet even people
that aren't Christians would get a lot
out of this book okay that's unwanted by
Jay stringer and we'll put the link to
that below we don't work for that book I
don't never I've not heard of that book
but I support the fact that this man
called in and recommended it to it about
sexual brokenness this is a tough thing
and look that's the thing is going on
now you know it's not Vera and so people
are are trying to stay off that bust and
I'm one of those people you know I'm one
of those people because I want to have
those feelings I want to have that
sexual comfort work you know that you
know and be that crazy guy you know I
want to be that Horace Grant for a lady
you know I want to be in the paint doing
work I don't want to be always on the
outside just
BJ Armstrong and in the distance you
feel me I want to be that hgz
I want to have the goggles on and be
doing work against the board's baby and
those are some old Chicago Bulls
references what else is going on what
have I been thinking about oh they have
this trail of um not a trail they have a
tribe I guess you would say maybe of
Hondurans allegedly coming towards the
US border I was thinking about this a
lot because this is you know this is
like a new thing that you know the media
really blasts out and uses is like a
scare tactic and a thing you know but
it's also a real thing that there are
real people who are experiencing some
sort of trauma or something in their
country and they have left their country
in our you know caravanning towards the
US and it makes me think a lot about you
know a lot about illegal aliens or you
know you know immigrants people come to
the US you know when I checked out my
father came here legally from Nicaragua
in 1922 I believe people have come
legally illegally over the years we know
that I I love the idea of having a very
legal system for people to get into the
country I love this I thought about this
could be a neat idea that look I'm all
about strengthening up the borders
making so you know who's coming in it's
just not safe to not know who is around
you know it's like a roll call I wish
every year we did a roll call where we
just where everybody had to go next door
there exact next neighbor and find out
who in the [ __ ] they were and do a book
report on their neighbor because we
don't know it you can't keep
you can't run a good company if you
don't know the inventory you can't do it
and here's what I thought though I
thought this is a lot of the issues are
mistreating people are people being
mistreated you know there's so many
great people in America in the world I
was thinking we should the part of the
program for having elite people who are
not already legal citizens of the US
part of the program could be that there
is a you can sign up to help someone you
can sign up to foster a family - okay I
can help to Honduran people can stay at
my place for this much time you know
they can stay here for this much time I
can help for this you know I they can
stay and work with me doing I feel like
there would be a really great program of
people that want to help and then people
that need help because that's really
what you're dealing with but I think
that then you would have an exact
account of what's going on you'd have
somebody to help somebody get acclimated
into what it's like to be in America or
what it's like to live in a new place
and then you solve a lot of that problem
then you because otherwise we don't know
what it's like for people living right
on the border you know and suddenly
people are in their yards and running
and they're starving and scared or
thirsty we we don't know what that's
like if we're not right there you know I
just feel like we could have a smarter
program overall to help people come in
what do I know
you know what am I know I'm just
thinking out loud alright let's get to
another call nine eight five six six
four nine five zero three eight Chad in
Iowa and you know I love Iowa you know
my heart has been I've been getting
these ideas in my brain and in my heart
over the past couple months to do a
comedy tour like a rural just middle of
nowhere comedy tour not middle of
nowhere because nowhere is is someone's
everywhere you know nowhere is is
you know my nowhere might be you know
might be your somewhere
you know your everything but but I'm
trying to think about how you know doing
a rural comedy tour and I mean just
getting out there boy someplace you
could buck miss smell the bacon you know
some people a place where if you see it
you see somebody eating a couple of vom
you know you see somebody having that
Nightingale egg omelet you don't look at
them sideways
let's take more onward not too many of
us I was just looking through the
responses to your pee problem here
you're drinking violet there oh yeah and
he's talking about when I was having
urinary troubles in Phoenix when I was
at the urine a um the urine their urine
null and couldn't get that I couldn't
get that faucet to pop let's go the
first I was glad to hear somebody call
with the mathematical thing that is
absolutely true the part of your brain
that controls math also for some reason
controls your P your your research or
whatever I don't get it biology but that
is absolutely true dude you don't even
have to go through the tables just go
what's 57 times 3 and even the idea of
thinking of that you're gonna be pissing
before you know it just make up some
number what's 273 plus 9 day you're
Pippen and there you go and he's saying
a cholera Cullen is suggested to me that
I do math when I'm at the urinal and
apparently that's a real thing then that
if you just start doing math this
gentleman from Iowa is saying that that
if you do math that part of your brain
that does math also you know is the year
is they is the runs the urinary the URI
the urethra so there you go you know I'm
saying if you divide it they will piss
is what I'm saying and that's full I'll
I'm talking Dyersville baby I'm talking
Dyersville all right but so there you go
try the mat if you are having trouble at
the year at the urinal you know other
guys around you're a grunting and piss
and in doing all kind of stuff juggling
they're doing it right they're making
fire and you're really standing there
just struggling to get your match to
flare do math all right let's take
another call that came in homework hey
Theo this is Josh from Sacramento
California Josh from Sacramento baby sac
town that's the Diaz brothers country
son I think Arness Stockton Sacramento
though we're a home amiss dude everybody
in Sacramento looks like a missing
person bruh beautiful place man also who
dat shout-out to my Saints I forgot
about that yeah man I love you I love
the New Orleans Saints homework just
want to say thanks I love the podcast I
think every week you always bring
something new something fresh something
funny for all of gang gang members out
here during gang papa
I just finished listening to the episode
not member wanted to say I think it's
awesome that you create a space for all
of us dudes who have struggled with you
know blowing loads into our hands and
stuff we said it right out like that man
he said it making that little you know
the sweet cream like big Richard used to
say he was making back there and he was
a guy who was a convicted PDF file in my
area when I was growing up big Richard
Homer on the frequent I think it's great
that you create a space for us so we can
help kind of overcome those things
together I'm a recovering that blower I
guess you could say oh yeah you out
there [ __ ] blast and pecans I'm daddy
not in the oral sexual waiver in the
masturbation it's okay man look hey but
if you want to suck a guy off you can do
it you know it's 2018 man
you can almost mean dude legally they
just made it legal you can date a second
cousin first cousin there's genetic
cross
/ you know you're gonna be double
dribbling you know what I'm saying
you're gonna you know I'm saying you're
gonna have a you're gonna have a baby
that can do the three-legged race by
himself but if you want to date a second
cousin man or polish him off with the
insides of your face you can do it let's
hear more sense of the term and just
want to say there's hope out there guys
you just gotta stick to it
the best thing that helps me get over
that was a competition I saw a
documentary or a fight or one at
masturbate before it spikes and you
would always win there you go so if
you're out there if you're not winning
right now and you just out there blowing
yourself out every night come on man
that there's just there's more to be
done there's more to be done but thank
you for that call um uh all right let's
take one more call here man uh homework
a Theo so to start this off I'm not sure
if this is a great question for you
personally and I don't mean that in a
bad way
look I don't take that in a bad way at
all man I'm just happy that you call
thank you I'm just not sure if you have
a lot of experience with this so it
might be more of a topic of question for
your listeners so I'm 18 it's been
dating this girl for the past six years
okay so you started dating you were 12
all work we've been together since
seventh grade you know recently she went
off to college and things have been kind
of weird since then and I think she's
getting to the point now where she wants
to break up and you know I just kind of
wanted your advice on that I mean she's
uh she's helped me through addiction
she's helped me through my parents
divorce depression you name it she's
been there and you know I like I said I
think she wants to break up now and I
was really hoping that you know
Thanksgiving break is coming up and I
was hoping that she would want to spend
that time together and try to work
things out more I'm not sure if that's
gonna happen soon oh man um I just love
her and really scared of what's gonna
happen I guess so my questions are how
do people deal with
a long-distance relationship and then
also if it does come down to breaking up
how do people deal with such a big
breakup because you know for me it's
almost a third of my life that we've
been together she's just always been
there she means absolutely everything to
me
she I don't know man I'm sorry if this
little confusing
um it's kind of hard to keep a thought
um yeah any advice that you can give the
awesome thing with your listeners excuse
me there thank you for the call man nah
I think this was you know this is
exactly what I wanted to you know glad
you called yeah cuz I don't want you
having to just think about this stuff by
yourself and get to swarmed up man I can
relate to this you know I had an
experience when I was in uh right when I
got out of when I got into uh you know
right around that high school college
time I was dating a girl and it was long
distance and she you know she was ready
to really kind of explore the world in a
lot of ways and meet new people and you
know some of these young men we we put a
lot of that on like you know her for me
anyway I just all I could think about
was her having hooking up with other
guys her hooking up with other guys but
really the truth was she just needed to
kind of be free you know and and I was
heartbroken man I was just heartbroken
when I remember I laid in the street in
my neighborhood and went even my
neighborhood I just laid in the street
somewhere and I was smoking um menthol
cigarettes you know because they had a
lot of brothers around me blowing out
all the time and I was you know doing
menthols and I wanted to just you know
and they were a lot of the time a lot of
black men were struggling in America so
I just wanted to just emulate any
struggle you know I just wanted to just
you know every hit I took off of that
menthol cigarette I just that was my
Amistad you know I just wanted to just
I don't know wanted to burn my insides
up because she wanted to move on and I
wanted to kind of stay I wanted to stay
where everything was the truth was I
mean yeah I was in LA I was really in
love with her at the time but also I was
just afraid of change you know I was so
scared of change but it sounds like men
you know this is somebody you've really
cared about and you said that she was
there for some really important times in
your life and sometimes you know
someone's in our life for a certain
amount of time for just four really
important things you know and it's kind
of great that you've had her for these
moments you know she sounds like a neat
person I don't even know her but I can
just feel it you know in the based and
the baritones in the back you know in
the back strap of your vocals I can hear
it in the Morea instruments you know I
can hear that she's probably a decent
person and here's the thing man you're
gonna have other chances with her it's
gonna be hard though it's gonna be hard
you have to stay busy your mind is gonna
be your worst enemy if you really start
to miss her you know when you're not
less than because she wants she's just
at a moment in her life where that's
gonna happen you know that there's a
setting free of this you know there's
this freedom that comes when someone
goes off to college and that mindset and
you have to find yourself now you have
to find out who you are you know
somewhat separate from her and it's
gonna take effort man I hate to tell you
that cuz I know it's probably gonna be
hard sometimes to you know stay
motivated or stay moving if you get
those thoughts in your head that she
doesn't care she's not thinking about
you or she's dating or doing other
things but you can do it you know you
can make better choices and just laying
on the street and smoking cigarettes you
know if I could go back in time I spent
more time with my friends
I would use that time to try and be
brave and even just go on dates but
there's a great chance it's hard to see
this when you're young and I'm not
preaching at you but it's hard to see
how many more opportunities you may have
to date or to be in love or to have an
experience with someone that you met
when you were younger yeah but it sounds
like me you guys have something really
special six years the only been alive
for eighteen and for six years you guys
have had each other in your lives that's
a long time you know and maybe something
that can help is to like kind of pray
for her and I'm not saying that you know
like in a Christian way but just you
know to think about her and wish the
best for her you know my father used to
pray for his enemies all the time and
eventually even though they never knew
it he cared about them because there's
something inside of us where if we kind
of wish for something or hope for
something enough or pray for something
enough to do well then we start to want
to we kind of support it instead of
dislike it you know so just praying for
her to be happy and you know and
eventually her being happy could could
bring her back your way will you have
another opportunity and look man I'll
tell you this I was in love with the
girl and she came back around years
later and dude I'm glad we didn't end up
to God she's a great girl but years
later she wasn't the same you know the
girl you love right now ten years from
now she could be doing gambling you know
she could be stealing she could be a
real real Chatty oh you don't want to be
a lifelong less than her brother you end
up with a real Chatty Cathy and they
have a couple you know some cinnamon
certs or they have some skittles or
something it's hard to listen to all of
it so you don't want you know you don't
know who she is really yet and this is a
chance for you it's gonna be this is
gonna be a really good chance for you so
I would just what I would think and try
and wish the best for her even when his
moment you don't want to you know man I
want her to do well I want her to be
happy I want her to have new experiences
and learn and and find have some joy in
her life you know and I think
that can help you do that for a couple
of weeks man it could help you get
through some of that because then you're
gonna be more supporting party who's
gonna want to support her instead of not
want to because we have this thing
inside of us if we cheer for something
even if we hate it eventually we'll
start to kind of actually want it to do
well and then that's such a better place
to be for us because now instead of the
feelings of hating something or
disliking an experience now we're like
so worth cheering it on but also those
are just my thoughts man and what do I
know you know I'm just a struggling man
in his 30s that's you know only got five
days off of his own ball bag so who
knows but I do know that I'm grateful
we'll be back here from Utah today and
I'm happy to be here with you guys and
be part of how this past weekend and
have this experience and and that's it
man you know we can get out of here we
can go off in our week the holidays are
coming up it's gonna come so fast cause
it's two weeks until Thanksgiving or
something like that or two in two days
or something start it now don't wait
wish happy holidays right [ __ ] now
boy I'll start wishing people that [ __ ]
right after Mardi Gras dude I'll be at a
funeral right after mark I'll be at a
funeral in June be like happy holidays
you know I'll be hanging mistletoe up
outside of out of damn wake you know
that's why man so it's a great time
don't let anybody make you feel bad for
being in the season for having that
feeling don't let anybody you know look
at you being joyous and make you feel
ashamed of any of your joy keep your
chestnuts off the open fire some of you
guys I don't know how many but people
been bustin out down there but hold on
hold the line you know you can do it and
be good to yourselves man because you
probably deserve it and I'm gonna try to
be good at myself you know we can do it
we can do it
let's head out with this song actually I
just thought of this would not love this
and this is um let's head out with this
song here we go
we got this
come on Kim I've seen oh man about a
hundred days I can almost your mama
bleep for pound restless take care of
yourselves
I made a dollar night spell but well
it's going me and I still get wet hug
somebody baby
[Music]
hit somebody with that he hit somebody
bacon hit somebody with that handful of
cinnamon you feel
you want to be in love with somebody let
somebody send them out of the palm of
your hand you want to talk about
pornography that's what I'm talking
about hit him with that old cinnamon
Wilson you feel me kind of like oh right
you want to do it anew pornography
reshape it put it into your relationship
in your marriage however you want change
the game these are old templates were
running on this is somebody else
invented this [ __ ] and we're letting
it live in ours in our heads and our
hearts and our lives come on man get
that cinnamon Wilson man old school you
want to show a lady a good time put a
little bit of sentiment you know in this
hand you know be that front open palm
she knows what's coming at her right
there
little handful of cinnamon do you let a
baby Gally lick some cinnamon off your
[ __ ] palms boy come along then you
hit her with that hidden fistful of
coriander on the other side and now
suddenly things is getting sweet
[Music]
bacon good night
this making it by bishop gun
most all of my plant you know what will
stay with it he's gonna switch out
if this bottle was an hourglass stop say
that I'm about an hour Cass
I'll shut it down
but actually you know what
[Music]
stuck with it and look is picking up see
we stuck with it and things are picking
up
[Music]
[Applause]
three the line
owning my skin but
[Music]
me
making good times man
[Music]
that is making it by bishop gun man I'm
riding their music for a long time now
but it helped me get through a lot of
this year in certain moments and this is
one of them you know making wrongs feel
right you know we're figuring it out you
gotta be good to yourselves you probably
deserve it
Allah I'll see you next next time thank
you